say the government is handing out money
or access to government property or some
other benefit can it exclude certain
kinds of speech or certain kinds of
speakers it's complicated but here are
the five rules of the First Amendment
and government property
rule one a few forms of government
property are treated as so-called
traditional public forums there the
government generally can't exclude
speech based on its content the classic
examples are sidewalks and parks as well
as streets used for parades and less
speech falls within one of the narrow
First Amendment exceptions such as your
threats of crime or face-to-face insults
that tend to provoke a fight the
government can't restrict it such places
are technically government property but
that gives the government no extra
authority to control such speech the
postal system is analogous at least
since the 1940s the Supreme Court has
held that the government can't exclude
certain kinds of content from the mail
to quote Justice Holmes in an early case
the United States may give up the post
office when it sees fit while it carries
it on the use of the mails is almost as
much a part of free speech as the right
to use our tongues rule too sometimes
the government deliberately opens up
property or funds in order to promote a
wide diversity of private speech using
objective criteria many public schools
for instance let's student groups use
classrooms that weren't otherwise being
used public libraries often offer rooms
for meetings of community groups public
universities might offer free email
accounts or web hosting to all students
and sometimes public universities offer
money to student groups to publish
newspapers or invite speakers these are
so-called limited public forums and the
government can limit them to particular
speakers for instance just students or
two particular kinds of speech for
instance just speech related to the
University curriculum it can also have
reasonable viewpoint-neutral exclusions
for instance saying that certain
benefits or property can't be used for
promoting or opposing candidates into
public office but it can't impose
viewpoint based criteria it can't for
instance let all groups use in a meeting
room in a library but exclude racist
groups rule 3 a lot of government
property is open to the public but not
for speech airports for instance are set
up to promote transportation not
speaking but people there will wear
t-shirts with messages on them talk to
friends maybe even approach strangers
with belief lights in these so-called
non-public forums the rule is much like
in limited public forums speech
restrictions are allowed but must be
reasonable
and viewpoint-neutral rule for some
government property is set up for the
government itself to speak and there the
government can pick and choose what
viewpoints it conveys or endorses the
walls of most public buildings are an
example the government can choose what
art to put up there and it might refuse
to display art that conveys ideas that
it dislikes likewise when the government
spends money to promote its own messages
it doesn't have to promote rival
messages it can have a National
Endowment for democracy without having
to fund a National Endowment for
communism it can put out ads supporting
racial equality without paying for ads
supporting racism sometimes there are
close cases for instance when Texas
authorized many kinds of license plate
designs but excluded Confederate flag
designs the court split five to four the
majority thought license plate designs
were government speech and the
government could pick and choose which
ones to allow even when the government
accepted dozens of designs requested by
private groups the dissent thought they
were limited in public forum in which
viewpoint discrimination was forbidden
because the government was supporting so
many different and often contradictory
forms of speech but while there were
close cases many are pretty clear the
government often clearly promotes views
it shows itself and sometimes clearly
promotes a wide range of private views
rule 5 similar principles likely applied
to government benefit programs and not
just a provision of real estate or money
charitable tax exemptions for instance
are likely a form of limited public
forum the government can discriminate
based on content you can't use
tax-deductible donations to support or
oppose candidates for office but not
based on a viewpoint likewise the
Supreme Court held that the government
can't deny full trademark protection to
trademarks that are seen as disparaging
scandalous immoral or racist
such restrictions the court said were
impermissibly viewpoint based of course
private property owners aren't bound by
the First Amendment whether they're
distributing money or access to real
estate and as we see the government as
property owner isn't bound by the First
Amendment quite the same as it is when
deciding whether to jail people or find
them for their speech but except when it
comes to the government's own speech
viewpoint discrimination is generally
forbidden even on government property so
to sum up the government generally can't
exclude speech based on its content in
traditional public forums the
government can deliberately open up
limited public forums that are
restricted to particular speakers or
kinds of speech but it can't impose a
viewpoint-based criteria in non-public
forums
speech restrictions are allowed but must
be reasonable and viewpoint neutral for
government property set up for the
government itself to speak the
government can pick and choose what
viewpoints it conveys or endorses
similar principles likely apply to
government benefit programs and not just
the use of physical property this is not
legal advice if this were legal advice
it would be followed by a bill please
use responsibly written by Eugene
Bullock who is an actual real-life First
Amendment law professor at UCLA I'm
Eugene Baalak and I approve this message
[Music]